The best book for non chemists to get a basic understanding of chemistry.
And what is your favorite fiction book?
I have no idea which book to recommend to you because books like
teachers, some people get on really well with one teacher.
Some people prefer a different teacher.
So it's which author you relate to.
I very much like the book by Primo LaVey called the periodic table,
but it may not suit everybody. I don't read very much fiction.
And if I do read fiction, I usually only read once.
What's the last fiction book you read. The
last fiction book I read was by, um,
Owen Matthews. I've forgotten his title.
It's a murder mystery set in a Russian
town in the 19 early 1950s.
When the H-bomb was being constructed there.
Videos, we often see experiments fail, but in a factory,
the same chemical reaction will be flawlessly executed with perfect
predictability. Why?
When we do experiments, we're doing them for the first time, at least for us.
So there are lots of things we don't know yet.
Yeah.
If you're building a chemical factory,
you will put in a lot of chemical engineering,
you will know all of the aspects of the reaction and you've
calculated the rates of reactions and so on.
So you've done the experiments hundreds of times,
and you've got it readily to work.
Working with so many different chemicals through the years.
I'm sure you've had a few scares,
but was there ever an incident when you were genuinely fearful for your life?
No.
I think chemists have to work safely.
I suppose the scariest incident they had was when I was a
student doing my doctorate and they put
500 pounds per square inch pressure of hydrogen gas by
mistake into a glass bulb.
And the bulb exploded and bits of glass
were found all over my hair,
but fortunately I wasn't injured at all.
We were in safety specs in those days,
people who wore glasses were not given safety glasses.
So I actually glued some state pieces onto one of my pairs of
glasses after that.
What is your best advice in teaching chemistry that will help me become an even
better teacher. First of all, let me say that. When.
I talk to professional chemists and ask them,
why did you become a chemist?
They nearly always say because I had an inspirational chemistry teacher
and I had a great teacher called Tony Roberts.
I'm Tony Roberts. I taught Martin chemistry 50 years ago.
I behave badly in his class, but he still inspired me.
So I think the most important thing for any sort of teaching is
enthusiasm. If you find the subject boring,
haven't helped the pupils.
So I think you've got to convey the idea that you think the work is
interesting and you like it.
I was once lecturing to students about something I thought was really boring.
Substitution and octahedral cobalt complex is the whole
class was silent. And I suddenly thought, gosh,
they think it's interesting.
And I worked myself up into such a state of excitement that I couldn't
do anything for the rest of the morning.
Dear professor Poliakoff, what is your favorite cheese?
I don't like blue cheese very much, but I like most other cheeses.
I once published the paper with my colleague, George Davidson,
analyzing cheese, in fact,
analyzing low fat cheese and comparing with normal cheese.
I was so embarrassed that I published a paper with the word
cheese in the title that I didn't put it in my CV
for many, many years.
What's wrong with having cheese in the title?
Well, I thought it was not very didn't sound very scientific.
What will you do when you retire?
One can never foresee the future,
but I'm not planning to retire immediately, but who knows?
What's going to happen to one in the future.
How many periodic table ties do.
You have? I'm not sure because I have two collections,
one at home and one here at the university and the.
University one.
And the tires sometimes travel between the two.
I think it's more than a dozen.
I rarely wear a tie without the periodic table on
it. I've never even gone really dark one that is suitable for funerals.
You can't really see the elements very well, but I know they're there.
I have a theory which might
amuse some of you that wearing a tie may help mitigate
global warming because you see when you have a tie,
it constrains your collar around your neck.
So hot air gets trapped in your shirt.
So you feel warmer so you can turn the heating down.
So if you wear a tie less CO2,
it's discharged in the atmosphere. So save the planet and wear a tie.
How do you relax in your free time sleep?
You go to the movies a lot.
So I go to, well, my wife is very keen on cinema,
so we go quite a bit to the cinema.
And you probably know that my brother is a movie director and
writer. You can buy his DVDs on Amazon.
So I do enjoy going to send them out.
And my mother was an actor though. She didn't perform very much,
but there is a big tradition of performing in our family.
Is it true that you sometimes leave when you're bored and go and work out in the
corridor though and leave your wife for what you're on her own?
Yes. Um, the cinema has very good wifi.
And so if the film bores me or frightens me,
I go out and work on my computer.
A lot of people asked about this.
What advances in chemistry will be most important for preventing or
mitigating climate change besides wearing ties?
I think the important thing is to find ways of providing
energy without generating CO2 or
large amounts of CO2.
It is not just a question of chemistry because it involves lots of engineering.
The chemistry may be the underlying principle,
but getting it to work on a lot of scale is definitely engineering.
So engineers and chemists have to work together.
The really important things that need to be done is to learn how to
harness the energy from the sun really efficiently.
For example,
new catalyst to split water into hydrogen and oxygen,
using sunlight.
Then you can burn the hydrogen to fuel cars and other sorts
of transport. Then there is the question of batteries.
So you can store electrical energy that you've generated with photo cells,
making cheaper photo cells that last longer that use
all of the spectrum of the light from the sun.
My hope is that chemists are going to succeed.
If they don't, we'll all fry.
As the temperature just goes up and up in the Earth's atmosphere.
We had so many questions about this, I guess I better ask,
how do you maintain your majestic hair? How do you prepare it?
What's your hair regime?
So my hair is what I was born with and I don't do
very much apart from occasionally brushing it.
I haven't been to a barber since 1967.
My wife cuts my hair occasionally
when she's persuaded me that it looks totally ridiculous.
[Inaudible].